>> Greg: I GUESS IT'S TIME FOR
OUR --
♪ ♪
>> GREG GUTFELD PRESENTS I
REALLY, REALLY, REALLY, REALLY
[BLEEP] HATE THESE PEOPLE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WITH THE BAILOUT PLAN
ON DEBT FEDERAL LOAN BORROWERS
MAKE AN 250K SEE THEIR LOAN DEBT
REDUCED BY TEN GRAND.
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF TAX
DOLLARS TO REWARD DOPES WHO
RACKED UP DEBT FOR USELESS
DEGREES TO WATER PEOPLE PLAN TO
DO WITH THE EXTRA CASH?
THEY SIPHON FOR PLUMBER'S WORK
AND FAMILIES SMART ENOUGH NOT TO
PURSUE GENDER STUDIES.
[LAUGHS]
INTELLIGENT.COM SURVEYED OVER
12 AND A PEOPLE WHO APPLIED OUR
PLAN TO APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM
AMONG THE FINDINGS 73% PLAN TO
SPEND A DEBT FORGIVENESS ON
NONESSENTIAL THINGS.
I TRAVEL, DINING OUT, AND NEW
TECH GADGETRY.
SO'S NONESSENTIAL CHASING THE
NONESSENTIAL.
AND TWICE AS MANY DEMOCRATS SAY
IT'S ACCEPTABLE TO SPEND THE
MONEY ON NONESSENTIALS.
BUT IT WAS HARD TO FIND ON
DEMOCRATS FOR THE SURVEY HERE IS
THE MOST INSANE ONE.
77% ADMIT THAT THEY COULD USE
THE MONEY MORE WISELY.
ASSUMING LIKE A SAVINGS ACCOUNT,
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION OR THE VERY
LEAST A FISHING ROD.
IN OTHER WORDS EVEN THE PEOPLE
IN THIS BAILOUT KNOW IT'S WRONG,
BUT THEY DON'T GIVE A [BLEEP]
BECAUSE CANCUN HERE WE COME.
I HAD GREAT TIMES THERE.
THAT DOESN'T STICK IN YOUR
BROUGHT YOU NEED TO GET YOUR
CROSS-EXAMINE.
OR SLAIN ANY WHAT THE HELL
ACROSS IS.
I WOULD TO THE DOCTOR LAWRENCE.
[LAUGHS]
I WAS SURPRISED BY THE SIZE.
WHAT IF YOU'RE KEEP DOING IT.
IT IS TO KEEP DOING IT.
AND THEN HE GAVE ME AN OINTMENT.
>> Kat: WERE GOOD, WERE GOOD.
>> Greg: ARE YOU IS UPSET
ABOUT THE STUFF AS I AM?
I'M SORRY ABOUT THE BAILOUTS.
I GONNA DISAGREE WITH ME?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT HE IDENTIFIES AS A BIRD
LET HIM HAVE IT.
>> Lawrence: CAN I BE HONEST?
I'M 29.
I'M IN A GROUP SO LET ME SAY I'M
NOT INCENTIVIZED, AND TO PAYING
FOR IT ANYWAY.
BUT I MAY HAVE PUT THE MONEY FOR
MY LOANS IN A DIFFERENT ACCOUNT
TO SEAL THIS PLAYS OUT.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT FAIR.
I HAVE IT THANK GOD BLESSED TO
BE HERE I GOT A LITTLE.
OKAY?
SOME OF THE CHANGE AWAY I CAN DO
IT BUT ONLY SEAL THIS PLAYS OUT.
BECAUSE I BE STUPID.
>> Greg: LOUD YOU PAID OUT?
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT TO TAKE
STOMACH THAT'S FREE.
COULD BE A BETTER PERSON
LAWRENCE BUT I'VE GIVEN UP ON
THAT.
>> Lawrence: WOW.
>> Greg: HERESY OF DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE?
>> Tyrus: FOR A GUY WHO BOUGHT
HIS TRUCK AND A HAMMER AND WENT
TO WORK TO TO GET A CHECK FOR
THAT?
OR THE MOM AND DADDY DIDN'T GO
ON VACATIONS THE PUT MODEL
JOHNNY THROUGH SCHOOL JUST FOR
THEM TO TELL ME NEVER LOVED HIM
ENOUGH BUT THEY LIKE THAT MONEY
BACK.
IT GOES BACK TO THE SAME THING
THAT IS TO LEARN THE LESSONS,
FREE MONEY IS ALWAYS BAD.
OF COURSE THEY ARE NOT GONNA
SPEND IT ON WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO, THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE DOING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
YOU GOT YOUR MONEY FOR EDUCATION
NEED TO BUY BOOKS?
NO YOU WENT TO CANCUN.
AND THEN YOU CALLED HOME FOR TOP
RAMEN AND MONEY FOR BOOKS
BECAUSE THEY'RE PHYSICALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE AND YOU ENCOURAGE
IT.
SO WHEN I SEE THIS I LAUGH OF
COURSE LISA BEING HONEST ABOUT
IT NOW.
UNLIKE SPIRIT AIRLINES I'M
SURPRISED THEY SOLD BECAUSE HER
TO BE BUSY FOR NEXT YEAR AND A
HALF.
THAT'S WHERE THE DOING.
>> Lawrence: THIS ME OF SAVE
THE DEMOCRATS THE LAST ELECTION
AS A RESULT THESE WENT TO THE
BALLOT BOX.
THEY BOUGHT THE VOTE I DIDN'T
THINK OF ACTUAL WORK.
>> Greg: IT WAS A BRIBE.
IT ALSO PITCHES ME OFF THAT IT'S
A BRIBE THAT HELP THE DEMOCRATS,
BUT WE ARE PLAYING FOR THE BRIBE
AT LEAST A MAFIA WHEN THEY BRIBE
POLITICIANS IT WAS THEIR MONEY.
>> Glenn: I'M ABSOLUTELY
SHOCKED WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST
GIVES PEOPLE MONEY WITH
OVERSIGHT AND THEN THEY WASTED
I'M BAFFLED, I'M SHOCKED.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
[APPLAUSE]
DEAR SWEET GREG HAS NEVER
COMMITTED A CRIME IN YOUR ENTIRE
LIFE I WOULD JUST LIKE TO LET
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THE MAFIA'S
MONEY.
>> Greg: I KNOW, I KNOW I KNOW
I UNDERSTAND >> Kat: THEM OFF
YOU GET ALL OF ITS THROUGH HARD
WORK.
>> Greg: DOES THIS WEIRD THING
IN THE SURVEY THAT SAID 80% OF
MEN --
I DON'T KNOW.
MEN SAY THAT SPENDING ON
NONESSENTIALS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO COMPARED TO 67% OF ONE OF
THEM.
SO WOMEN.
>> Lawrence: PUT YOUR GLASSES
ON.
>> Greg: APPARENTLY THERE ARE
A DIFFERENCE IS YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
SAVED IT.
>> Kat: FIRST OF ALL GREAT
JOB.
[LAUGHS]
WELL OKAY ON THE ONE HAND WITH A
LOT OF THE STUFF THAT'S GOING ON
COLLEGES THESE DAYS YOU PROBABLY
COULD LEARN MORE AT A CHILI'S SO
IF THE GOING THERE AND SPENDING
THIS MONEY TO GO OUT TO DINNER
OKAY I'M NOT A BIG RULES PERSON,
BUT I LOVE TO MAKE THIS RULE
WHERE IF YOU DO USE THIS MONEY
YOU GOT FOR FREE BECAUSE HER
STUDENT LOANS TO LITTLE
RESTAURANT WE SIT DOWN AT THE
TILL YOUR SERVER THE BATTERY
DOING.
THIS MAY BE YOUR SERVER DIDN'T
GET TO GO TO COLLEGE AND THEY
NEED ME DIFFERENT DECISION HEY
JUST SO YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR
THIS MEAL THE YEAR I SHOULD FOR
BECAUSE HE CHOSE LIGHT SHOW
STILL [BLEEP] OFFER FOR YEARS.
>> Greg: AMEN.
[APPLAUSE]
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD HAVE A
RIGHT SO IF YOU'RE AT A RESORT
IN THE PERSON NEXT TO YOU TELLS
YOU HOW THEY PAID FOR IT AND YOU
LIKE OKAY YOU FOR RIGHT TO BEAT
THE --
UNLESS THE ONE OF THESE GUYS.
>> Lawrence: GREG, WHO ARE YOU
GONNA BEAT UP?
YOU CAN EVEN SEE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I UNDERSTAND.
>> Tyrus: HE DOES IS FIGHTING
WITH EMAILS, SCATHING EMAILS OF
DISAPPOINTED SOME ANGER.
>> Kat: WERE NEVER TO LET IT
GO.
>> Tyrus: FROM A SAFE DISTANCE
IN HIS LITTLE CABIN.
WITH HIS DOG WHINING ALL NIGHT.
LOOK I'M TRYING TO WRITE.
>> Kat: I LOVE WHEN YOU CALL
IT THE WRITERS CAV